corey promised me a lot of things like
learning spanish and engaging with my
family
and nothing of that was happening so i
wasn't ready to marry him yet because i
didn't thought you were ready either
[Music]
i don't know where you stand on things i
want to walk the world with you but not
because
you need me but because we both want to
evelyn decided she wanted to go on a
break and i took that as we were broken
up
which we were broken up it wasn't taking
a break you broke up with me
first it was a break
but you did break up with me right
i just wanted corey to see that he could
lose me and try to show some effort into
actually doing the things that he
promised me
i was devastated
i was heartbroken and i just wasn't
right in my head
[Music]
i decided to go to peru
it's cheap there's good surf and it's
close after a month in peru i figured it
was time to head back to ecuador
gather all my things and move on
but at that moment is when quarantine
happened
you know right now you and i wouldn't be
together who weren't stuck before
then
evelyn found out through a friend that i
was seeing another girl while i was in
peru
once i found out about corey hanging out
with this jenny in peru
i mean of course at that time i was mad
but he told me that he only hang out
with her for four days
but after i kept pressuring him he
admitted there was more to the story
[Music]